what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
fresh and fit
podcast clip labeled she hates men and
wants to kill them
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers and each and every one of
you helps me get to that
goal okay
[Music]
men compartment lies more than you all
think y'all just don't understand your
minds because you're not really
all there sometimes are you a man damn i
feel like that
every time i talk to a man that's how it
is like y'all
y'all don't even understand your own
[ __ ] thoughts sometimes when women we
think about this [ __ ] in the night in
the dark in the middle
when we wake up like we literally think
about every action every conversation
y'all probably just forget about what
y'all just said five seconds ago
uh no we actually don't that's actually
but okay let's read this real quick
okay okay uh yeah this is sell 100
uh i know math is hard that's why the 99
is troubling
uh respect though to the fellas donating
to bolster the setup thank you
brother thank you um i will say this um
[Music]
men uh i don't even know how to
like you just said so many things there
that are incorrect uh it really
i think they are yeah i'm gonna take us
men are men are men are logically based
so like with us when we do what we do
it's all logic and rationale
like you just admit that you have
friends of different groups to serve
certain benefits
but that's how men are but you just guys
don't even think about it but you
logically do that [ __ ]
but you don't think about it no you have
business associates sure oh
so there's a different compartment
already yeah but you call them
associates they're not friends like
girls will fake
fake it and be like oh my god girl
you're so beautiful blah blah blah like
you guys will
lie to each other how is that a lie like
if i think somebody's beautiful that's
how we met i was like
girls all the time say i love your dress
when in reality they don't mean i don't
know about your guy
i don't
i feel like that's the stuff you only
see in movies
i would not tell someone that i like
their outfit if i did i'm trying to like
think
like if i've actually done that
i don't know i can't think of a time i
should not compliment somebody if i do
like i do agree like women are more
emotional than men like in general
i mean not always obviously but like in
general they tend to be more emotional
i think there's no more no cap
relationship than mine
revolve the world doesn't revolve around
you i'm saying i'm just saying
absolutely not
not a lot of women don't get along with
each other and a lot of women are catty
and they don't like matter of fact
right which is why i was actually
talking about this the other day like
girls are more like they'll talk about
you behind your back
where guys will like say stuff like to
their
face where like girls like you can be
like i've seen girls where they're
literally like best friends with each
other and like one of them will talk
about the other behind their back like
all the time i wouldn't compliment
somebody cut me off
i've had women come on the show plenty
of times and they'll say oh i don't like
hanging out with girls i prefer to hang
out with guys
why is that well because there's nothing
who aren't going to show it right now
are the women or us too well i'm i'm
going off my experience i mean
we're generalizing here right you're
saying guys don't know that but you can
generalize if we can generalize it
different from experiences we've had as
well you feel me like
i have a lot of guy friends but of
course i prefer woman companionship
i'm different you're dealing with two
different women in this circumstance no
that's cool but i'm talking
we're speaking in generalities right now
but your general is different from my
general
we have a bigger bro how old are you 26.
okay
31 28 and we've had hundreds of girls
determine
experience 100 a lot of the times
i i guarantee we've we've lived more
life than you guys don't think that
women come in contact with more
i don't know but their experience is
like very specific like they talk to
miami girls it's like a very
specific type of girl so i don't
like he's just automatically right for
women like conversations
relationships like come on how many
times you you watch your girls go to the
bathroom and stay there for like 30
minutes because she's talking to
somebody or
a bunch of [ __ ] women in the bathroom
you talk to people professionally
professionally we just talk to women in
the bathroom no i'm saying i'm saying we
talk to people for like it's our job
we're here on a podcast right now right
every night i'm just saying you don't
have everybody's viewpoint
okay anyway
okay okay okay um next question yeah uh
yeah she said was the the question was
what's our first impression
i already gave my answer so what's your
question now no no that was her question
oh that was hers okay now you're going
or not
oh my gosh that means i have to think
okay like i said i'm
terrible at asking other people
questions but if i had to ask you guys
one
you don't have to good cause i don't
really want to can you guys just ask me
questions
okay cool sure there you go um but
people want to know uh
how many people have you had sex with ms
blondie body count i'm telling you guys
it's that's not something i want to
share for the world but i did say it was
lolo and i'm going to keep it at that
because it's the truth so i just don't
feel like sharing it with thousands of
people is it double digits no
not yet that's good neither okay i don't
believe that but
looking at myself okay another person's
perspective i would not think that
either you know i do only fans for a
living but you guys there's there's also
stories that's why people do that you
know
um i have easy money
no not right right i'm just saying
that's just another reason i just
i understand my image is just like i
wouldn't blame anyone for thinking it's
i wasn't even thinking about any fans no
but i know that was just an example of
why
like people might think it could be
double digits i mean i'm a hoe to the
to the view to the naked eye like you
see me and that's my image i make myself
look like that i dress like that i put
myself on the internet like that
but that's not who i am it's not what i
like if you ever were to approach me in
public and i don't know you
you're probably gonna get slapped if you
dare even say hi to me touch me breathe
near me
try to approach me i don't like men in
general i do not like men i don't like
being touched
i don't like oh my god
oh my she just openly touch i don't i
don't want to be hollered at
don't whistle at me i [ __ ] hate men
so questions
oh my gosh that's just nuts that she's
gonna openly say that like
i mean she shouldn't say that at all but
she's like comfortable enough saying
that on a public platform
that's it's your own fault like if you
pick
guys that make you hate men that's like
your own fault
yep thank you goodbye okay wow i mean
okay i don't even think about that guys
i do pay her only fans
no questions so you're saying you hate
the cat calls and everything right
when do you when you dress like that
what do you i'm not asking for that i'm
feeling good about myself and i mean i
feel like so many women have [ __ ]
said that
i'm not [ __ ] dressing for you to sit
there and [ __ ] whistle at me what's
wrong with you freaks
you know what i'm saying i'm doing it
because i feel good about myself and i
wanted to wear this into the mic
sorry my ears so so question for you
right if i have a lamborghini right
i'm gonna go park it in the hood and
keep the doors unlocked
okay what's gonna happen i mean i guess
you're gonna get stolen from
cool so if you wear the outfit on public
that's cool if you do it but that
doesn't mean i sleep around with people
i definitely did it to myself i make
myself look a certain way if you're
gonna cat call me that doesn't mean i
like it but it's gonna happen and i'm
aware of that you know what i'm saying
but it's not
i don't sleep around and that that's my
answer to the question i definitely look
like
you know a hoe to the to the person
who's looking at me but i'm not hello
kelly we don't judge you for what you do
i'm just telling you you know i know
you're not judging but but
i'm gonna judge you for the math i don't
know math i know that's why i said
the body's not might not be kidding
she didn't count a bunch of them she's
like oh no no this is a cowboy okay
i like him she's cool yeah okay um let's
see here where are we at okay so we got
some super chat
though we're gonna read 50 and up man
you're not funny so we don't like
interrupt the show too much
uh only rappers making above 500k count
as part of her body count hilarious no
and that is what md thank you so much um
and then uh yeah
nobody's gonna put up with somebody
obnoxious and plastic
uh best find the most better man and put
a ring on it otherwise you're gonna be
part
playing you're gonna be a play thing
until you're used and then tossed
seriously if i want a date with you i
would turn it down what's your rebuttal
i just think that that was unnecessary
completely well you did you did call him
a bum earlier and oh in that case then
you probably
are and i hope that you drop dead get
called and help somebody
she's kind of funny i mean she's crazy
but she's kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] killed
oh my god
i feel like half the guy the people that
send like comments like that are just
like
kids like trolls are more followers than
you'll ever have
in your muffins what was coach gregon
super chat right there
damn i don't know
guys i feel like the girls that they
have on the show are like
literally like very specific to i'm not
saying like
they don't like they don't exist and
they're not there they're just like
where i grew up i did not meet like
a lot of females that like had only fans
or like were involved in that type of
stuff
so it's just interesting to me to like
watch it from like the outside looking
in
so to speak but let me know in the
comments what you guys think if you
agree or you disagree
um do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time